hello everyone and welcome to Thermo
Fisher Scientific webinar series on
Sanger sequencing and fragment analysis
made easy corresponding with the launch
of applied Biosystems new seeks to do
genetic analyzer today we present the
fourth topic in the series genome
editing workflow facilitated by the
thermo Fisher Scientific portfolio
solution presented by dr. Steve Jackson
a product application specialist for
Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm Suzy Valdez
and I'll be your moderator for today's
educational webinar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also notice you're viewing
this presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon on the lower right if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support button
at the top right of your presentation
window I'll use that Q&A button and let
us know you're having a problem I'd now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Steve Jackson dr. Jackson has over ten
years of experience in genetic analysis
technology as a senior member of the
genetic analysis R&D team at Thermo
Fisher Scientific he helps develop
solutions for the research and health
care markets leveraging varied
technologies such as capillary
electrophoresis digital PCR
next-generation sequencing and
microarray analysis please join us now
in welcoming dr. Jackson I will now turn
the presentation over to him welcome dr.
Jackson Thank You Sussie
and thank everybody for joining today
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
how Thermo Fisher Scientific can help
you with your workflows that are doing
genome analogy no editing problems as
most of you know the genome editing
technologies are poised to really
revolutionize the way that we understand
biology it will allow us to do many
different things including the things
shown here on this slide anything from
making models of human disease in mice
and other animals to making diseases and
plants even gene therapy research for
example these technologies which include
CRISPR
talent and zinc fingers can help study
gene functions
nici gene mutations tag genes no.4 for
other purposes stabili integrating new
sequences really almost anything that is
biologic can be modified using these
genome editing applications what I'm
going to focus on today is mostly at the
CRISPR caste 9 system on this is
originally a system that was identified
in bacteria as a primitive way for them
to fight off viral infections the way
that we have made use of the CRISPR cast
line system is that the caste 9 nucleus
is guided to a particular target by a
guide RNA once the nucleus and the guide
RNA complex finds the target sequence a
cut is made in the genomic DNA locus
that has been targeted and then that
genomic DNA that cuts no DNA is then
repaired either in a non homologous
fashion making sloppy changes or if is
provided with the template you can make
insertions appointments take your point
mutations or GFP sequences for example
or basically anything at all so the
system is very simple to use
and as I mention here on the slide it
makes it possible to make single
nucleotide changes their size deletions
and insertions imprecise or sloppy
deletions if you want to knock out the
virginal function of a gene you make
deletions at multiple loci just
basically anything you want to do you
pretty much can do using dstean editing
technologies now
Fisher scientific as you know is a very
big company with a very diverse
portfolio and we have been developing
this these technologies over the course
of our last 10 years or so to make
things easy for the user to do these
type of experiments anything from
designing the guide RNA that will help
you target the right locus in your
genome through the cell transfers
meaning to identify the cells that have
the change needed and finally that the
ultimately that the phenotypic analyses
at the very end which allow you to study
the function of the type of mutation
that you've made here and again we have
anything from genetic analysis tools
through mass spectroscopy
flow cytometry types of work workflows
and anything needed to characterize that
by the Edit that you made in your around
in your cells so to kind of show you how
this is going to work we've done some
proof of concept studies we've made use
of the predesigned a human GCD primer
database we have basically designed
primers against for CRISPR and Talon
against all the human genes so you can
make sloppy knockout mutations and and
therefore you know make loss of function
genes we basically chose some of these
guide RNAs from several different genes
from this this pre designed knockout
collection we introduced these into 293
cells or a 549 cells by transfection
along with the guide our with the cast 9
nucleus needed to make the edits and
then we prepared extracts from these
primary transforming pools
these pools that have contained mixed
populations of edited and not in edited
cells and we mostly want to try to
analyze how efficient was the edit that
we that we designed how many cells have
the edit delete that we wanted to make
because the the efficiency is key for
determining how many cells in the
secondary screen you want to analyze
downstream so you want to know how
efficient was the the to edit you made
in the first place
and we have different tools available
for that I also want to point out that
the we also have tools available if you
don't want to make use of our
pre-designed libraries we also have the
ability to make custom tools our
customer guide RNAs for whatever purpose
that you want to have for your research
so the first method for determining
efficiency is very simple it's called a
genomic cleavage detection by ah gross
gel electrophoresis and the way that it
works is that you first start off by by
transfecting your cells you then prepare
a lysate of these of these cells by just
lisen and basically in a new and a PCR
friendly buffer you then amplify using
primers do you nature using just you
basically heat up the the mixture and
let it read anneal when that when that
occurs you get mismatches of unedited
versus edited or edited versus different
edits amplicons these these loop out
mismatches are now substrates for a
single strand nucleus here and so you
add the single strand nucleus to this
mixture and where there's a loop out
where there's a mismatch indicating
where there's an edit then you break a
larger amplicon into smaller amplicons
these are then readily observed on an
agarose gel and so what I'm showing here
now is the output of one of these
experiments where we have the parental
band shown the parental band shown here
what's shown here this is the intact
amplicon of the full-length size that
that is indicating there has not been a
cleavage event there has not been an
edit or there's been no nucleus added
but you can see also is that there are
smaller cleaved bands which indicate
that the sizes of the fragments that are
produced as a result of this mismatch
that happens here and and by summing up
that the by dosimetry the amount that is
in the cleavage products with the with
the amount that's in the unclean product
so you can get an idea of how efficient
the edit was and this in this example
here we have anywhere
from 10.8% to 21.5%
edit in a different experiment here we
had a better efficiency you know about
around 45 46 percent the efficiency that
comes up so the agarose gels are a
pretty standard equipment found in
laboratories and this is pretty easy to
do these types of experiments the
problem is that that with agarose gels
you know it the the the absolute sizes
and the absolute cleavage percentages
are not easy to determine because you're
relying on dosimetry and imprecise ways
of measuring what's there so another way
of doing this is by using capillary
electrophoresis basically that the the
experiment works the same way we
transfer using your your your guide RNA
and and nuclease you allow the cells to
recover you paralyze eight you know as
we did before you then PCR amplified but
in this case you use a primer that has a
fluorescent tag at one end so now your
amplicons are going to be labeled at one
end you could go through the
denaturation rename duration as before
you do your your cleavage using the the
detection enzyme provided with the
geomat cleavage protection kit and now
instead of running an agarose gel you
analyze these by capillary
electrophoresis and the results will
look something like this in this case
we've modified the the hprt locus we
have amplicons that will query this this
locus here in this case we're showing
the hprt amplicon that has no guide RNA
added but has had the detection enzyme
all we get is a single strong peak at
about 470 nucleotides that tells you the
size of the of the amplicon that we
designed now in the case of no guide RNA
there's no editing event and so of
course there's no change in the size or
the position of this particular for
inserting it because I speak that's
shown here however when we take the same
cells and now we've added the guide RNA
we get a family of different sized Peaks
after enzyme cleavage so we have the the
intact parental 473 type band we have a
family of bands that are in the range of
29 2015 one entry tides
and we also have a smaller size here of
460 nucleotides
now because this 160 nucleotides appears
in the no enzyme capillary no enzyme
Lane what that's saying is that we have
deletions of around 10 nucleotides that
are pretty abundant and these are now
the the unclever but but different size
bands because there's been some of the
hprt locus deleted in the presence of
the enzyme you can see that that you
know the smaller sized bands are
indicating that we have a good amount of
cleavage a good amount of edit that has
happened here and it's producing
fragments that around turn 29 2015 one
nucleotides of around where the the
mismatch has occurred now using our
software it's pretty easy then to
calculate the fraction as present in
these cleaved bands versus the total
amount that's present in the cleaved and
unclean in this case we can calculate
the efficiency of the edits at this
locus being about 68% so one thing i
want to mention as well is that we just
recently updated our our software to do
this classically we have used a software
called chain mapper which is a great
piece of software but it's a little bit
unfurling to use we just released
something called peak scanner which is a
little bit cleaner interface but it does
the exact same thing that gene mcclure
does and here what we're showing is a
different experiment here where we have
on the top is the cleaved guide RNA
directed edit and on the bottom is the
the same lysate in the absence of enzyme
what we see here is that is the peak for
the intact parental amplicon and then
the family of Peaks that are indicating
that there has been a genomic edit and
again what you can do is you can
calculate the heights or the areas under
the curves to calculate the exact
precise genome editing efficiency
obtained in that experiment
next way that I'm going to tell you
about I makes use of Sanger sequencing
so in in this case if you if you take
the amplicon and try to send sequence
the amplicon what you will get is that
will find a region that is a pure
sequence meaning this is the part of the
of the amplicon has been unedited and at
the red arrow that I'm showing here and
downstream of that you have sequence
that is now very poorly resolved you
have multiple peaks that indicate that
this downstream of this arrow there is a
mixed population of sequences that are
here so by saying or sequencing the the
primary pool what you can see is that
you had a successful edit but it's
difficult to see exactly what is present
in that in that edited pool you can't
confirm the sequence you can't really
tell what the frequency of the of the of
the edit the efficiency of that edit was
going to be so there are a couple of
ways around that the first way is to is
to basically subclone these into
plasmids and the way this works is that
you take your primary pool of cells okay
after the edit you will then establish a
primary culture and now you just as I've
told you before the amplicon surrounding
the guide RNA now if some of these will
have an edit and some of these will not
you take this this mixed pool of an
applicant you know is shown here and
subclone it into a topo containing
plasmid okay so now you're basically sub
cloning that amplicons establish a
individual bacterial colonies isolate
plasmid DNA from them in sequence that
the bacterial DNA the plasmid DNA each
of which is going to contain a fraction
of the edit that you have in the
original primary pool of edited cells so
you sequence these individual sub clones
now and then you can then identify the
types of edits that were made and the
frequency at which those edits were made
by counting the number of colony of
counting edits in individual colonies so
here we picked 96 different bacterial
colonies isolated plasma DNA in sequence
that hprt look is here what i'm showing
is that each one of these lines
indicates the plasmid sequence the
BRT locus in that plasmid from different
bacterial colonies and you can see that
there are the large changes that are
made or in some cases small changes made
deletions insertions lots of different
types of molecules get get made when you
do these kind of sloppy edits here the
on the top that's showing the guide RNA
sequence and then that the wild-type
hprt look is shown here in blue with the
red box around it the Orang are the
yellow with red typewriters are showing
the sequences that are that are unedited
that are unmodified in the whole
population and you can see that I've
been that a very large variety of
different types of edits were made so by
Counting that the number of colonies
that have an edit and comparing to the
fraction of the 96 that contain an edit
now you can get a frequency of the
editing efficiency in that particular
pool the other thing that doing this
this plasmid sequencing tells you are
the types of edits you can expect to see
in your edited eukaryotic cells now
another way of doing this which doesn't
incall involve plasmid sequencing it
makes use of software called tied this
is called the tracking of in Dells by
decomposition and it's developed by
investigators at the Netherlands Cancer
Institute in think it's an Amsterdam in
any event on what this software will do
is it will take a control sequencing
trace and a mixed sequencing trace as
shown down here and it will calculate
the frequency at which these these these
mixed pools can be explained by a minus
1 a minus 2 a minus 3 etc deletion
around the guide RNA the sequence that
you supply to them so when we do that
experiment using the hprt cells i
described for you what you can see here
is that on the forward strand here we
have a large fraction here which was
shown to have a plus 1 mutation a
fraction has a minus 1 a minus 2 minus 3
etc all the way to minus 10 and what the
tide software will do is it will it will
calculate the fraction that are
different from the zero okay so the zero
is shown here in the light pink here
these are the fraction that that
of the traces that can be explained by
by having no edits and it returns to you
a percent it's difficult to see here but
the percent here was calculated to be
about about 80% editing efficiency we
get basically the same profile on the
reverse strand here and about the same
frequency so what this tells you is that
we can expect that a majority of the
edits in this experiment contain a plus
one insertion but that will also be a
certain you know about 4% will have a
minus one about about 5% or so about 1
minus 2 etc so around 80 percent of a
total of around 80 percent of the of the
altered sequencing traces are present in
this hprt edited sequencing reaction
here now if you do the same thing with
using a different guide RNA of a
different locus in this case we chose
rel rel a and in this case you know we
got you know a fraction that was not
edited you know shown again in pink and
again we have a lot of the fractions
that were either minus 1 minus 2 minus 3
or plus 1 plus 2 Plus 3 going in the
direction got the same result results in
the for reverse strand over all the
editing efficiency for rel a was around
20% so a little bit lower than then with
the hprt and using other techniques that
I'll describe for you in a little bit
later I knew that this was a little bit
lower this 20% was lower than what
expected and one thing to keep in mind
is that in the tide software you can set
the window at which he looked for
insertions and deletions they didn't
basically edit and once you try to
deconvolution equals that are present
it's set by default at minus 10 if I
expand Lee at the window for these rail
ace SC sequencing traces I get a better
representation of what the actual
editing frequency was so on the top here
I'm showing the the the rel a sequencing
tray at I'd output with the default
window and again that editing efficiency
is around 25% in this direction but if I
expand the window so if I'm now looking
at everything from minus 25 to plus 25
what I get is what I see now is that
there are a larger fraction of
of sequencing traces now which have
deletions of greater than a -10 so up to
minus 1520 cetera and if we take into
account these these larger deletions now
we get a much greater editing efficiency
this case around 63% which is more in
line with what I've got using other
techniques using these these life states
so changing the in Dale size the size
range parameter in the tied software can
provide a more accurate determination of
the editing efficiency one final special
case I want to point out is if you are
constructing a snip mutation you're
you're basically expecting there to be
only a single mutation or a single
change in your edited cells I'm
indicating that here with the red arrow
so if you're expecting a snip we have
software called minor variant finder
which has been designed to look at the
presence of minor alleles present in
mixed sequencing traces such as we see
here these screenshots of a minor
variant finder and what we're looking at
is at the very bottom here is a control
sequencing trace in the in the forward
direction and in the reverse direction a
reverse trace I'm sorry a seizing traces
from a test sample again in the forward
and reverse direction as shown here and
then the output of minor variant finder
which will clean up the the background
in the Florida first direction and look
for a variants that are present at the
same position in the forward and reverse
direction in this case we have a g2 a
mutation which is in the corresponding
c-to-t position in there were strands
four alleles or four variants that have
this matched the minor variant finder
software will look up for the area under
the curve and calculate the frequency at
which this allele is present in this
case this this g2 a change was present
about twelve point nine in the four
direction
ten point eight in reverse direction so
overall about about eleven percent
frequency so a minor variant funder can
do for your genome editing experiments
is tell you if you have a mixed
population what fraction of those have
the edit or
have a snip of interests to you in that
to your camp economy so the last thing
I'll talk about is using digital PCR
this is another way you can quantify the
efficiency which the Edit is made by
judicious placement of TaqMan probes
what I'm showing you here is that we
have a particular locus we have in black
of forward/reverse PCR primers near in
here we also have designed a control
probe that's labeled with thick
it's a fluorescent dye just indicated by
red here and this control probe was
placed in a region of the amplicon that
is not likely to be edited not likely be
affected by the cast 9 nucleus and
repair mechanism of the other cells that
you want to be edited we design a second
probe here using fam that is over the
the edited site okay
and so what will happen is that in the
presence of unedited amplicons where
there has not been an edit both probes
will bind and you'll get both a vic
signal and a fam signal however where
there has been a genome edited there's
been an editing event that has taken
place the the fam labeled edit to probe
will not be able to bind but you will
get a signal from the control vic
labeled probe so we expect that that any
any kind of the of the reactions any
kind of the pcr wells that have no
cleavage they will be positive for both
famine vic where there has been an edit
it will be positive for vic but not fan
and there should be no wells and have
them only because that would mean that
the control probe is lost so as you
might know digital PCR basically will
divide a seeing reaction or i'm sorry a
pcr reaction into around 20,000
individual pcr wells we do the PCR and
simply count the number of wells that
have a vic probe a fan probe or both
what i'm showing here are four different
life states for different PCR reactions
here and what we get is that clouds of
wells indicating
clouds of positive reactions indicating
the status of the wells that were that
were counted so in this case here we
have this cloud of cells that were
positive for Vic only this cloud of
cells are positive for both Vic and fam
and we have this cloud of Wells which is
unamplified and by calculating the
fraction that is positive for the for
Vic only as opposed to Vic plus family
we can get an idea about what the
editing efficiency was and then we did
this basically for four different Llosa
and calculate the editing efficiency by
digital PCR so um we have present to you
lots of different ways you can quantify
the efficiency of genome editing and
what I'm doing on this slide here is
just showing you a comparison of the
different techniques for the same set of
life states from the same edited cells
so we have here is in the dark blue bars
we have the frequency calculate by
genome cleavage essay on agarose gels in
the orange the genome cleavage assay on
our legacy capillary electrophoresis
instruments in gray we have the the
genomic cleavage pass a as measured by
our brand new who seeks to do instrument
in yellow we have the editing efficiency
is calculated by tide and finally we
have the editing efficiency as to as
calculate by digital PCR and what you
can see is that for the most part the
frequencies are fairly agreeable they
are pretty much the same and there are
couple exceptions for example this this
GCD ah gross is a little bit higher than
everything else and that could you know
have to do with the dosimetry
and the other types of methods for
measuring that the density of the Bands
in that particular case in this case the
cd4 cdk4 live state had a little bit
lower digital PCR frequency that could
have been because of sub optimum
placement of some of the probes and
maybe a little bit of optimization of
the cdk4 apps they might have done a
better job and in this case that the
check for tide determination was little
bit lower than everything else and I
know that's because the
of the Chuck sequencing reactions were
not as good as as some of the other low
sigh but overall that the way the
different methods calculate efficiency
agree fairly well now there are
strengths and weaknesses to each one
these different types of fit techniques
and there isn't really one right answer
for for determining that what the
efficiency is going to be now whether
you have a knock out random sloppy
mutations I just talked about
snips defined deletions insertions or
translocations these can all be used to
measure the I'm sorry all these
techniques can be used to measure the
the efficiencies in these different
types of edits but they do so with with
differing efficient are differing
strengths okay for example a single tack
man genotyping assay will be very good
at determining whether or not you have a
snip that it made but for determining
what the the nature of your knockout
mutation is it's not going to be very
good it can be done but but it won't be
very very easy or very quantitative on
the other hand the gene art cleavage
assay is going to be great for
determining your efficiency at producing
random knockout mutations but it's not
going to be very good at determining
whether you have a specific snip present
because you're going to be operating the
back line of all these other cleavage
events that are present so really that
the method chosen for determining the
efficiency of your of your edit and
recon depends on the type of edits are
making and not shown on the slide are
other things like workflow and cost and
not a sequencing sequence information
you get out of these experiments that
said so there are a lot of different
ways to that you can analyze your your
editing efficiency that are basically
you know up to what your question is if
your laboratory that the what I'm trying
to say is that thermal Fisher has all
the tools necessary for analyzing what
those events might be so
to conclude I have shown you the capelin
capillary electrophoresis methods can be
integral parts of your genome editing
workflow for determining edits in your
primary cultures the gene art header
duplex cleavage assay thought by franked
analysis on capillary capillary
electrophoresis can determine the
efficiency of your edits but also
analysis of Sanger sequencing traces in
using tied software or by sub clearing
the sample cons and the plasma is
followed by Sanger sequencing will also
help you determine how efficient and and
what was the nature of the types of
Pettus you have in your in your primary
pooling cells in addition calculator
capillary electrophoresis and particular
Sanger sequencing on C II is useful for
validating the edits and secondary
cultures but I didn't really go into is
the next step in this is that you you if
you want to isolate individual
homogeneous clones of eukaryotic cells
you sequence are you you isolate single
cells and you can Sanger sequence those
cells or use minor variant finer than
determining whether or not your
secondary pools of what you hope are
heterogeneous cells contain the edit
that you want lastly I want to point out
the thermo Fisher Scientific not only
has the tools necessary for analyzing
the efficiency of genome editing but we
also have the the cell cultural reagents
the ability to help you design guide
RNAs and synthesize guide RNAs and
finally doing the phenotypic analysis
from mass spectroscopy to transcriptome
analysis on microarrays etc so Thermo
Fisher Scientific has all the tools
necessary for let's discuss a successful
genome editing experiment finally I just
want to thank a number of the Ravinder
on the synthetic biology group for her
help in engineering lights with these
experiments and company varma and the
other members of our clanton Engine team
for their guidance arms and these
experiments also I thank you very much
for your time and I'd be happy to take
questions right now
thank you dr. Jackson for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of our webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that green Q&A button at the
lower left of your presentation window
typing your questions that appear on the
screen and click the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for today
okay let's take a look at our audience
questions already coming in dr. Jackson
here's our first question
I noticed you did not mention
next-generation sequencing is that a
technique that can be used for screening
can you hear me there we go
yes so next generation sequencing can be
very valuable for screening and for
subsequently examining the effect of
your mutations downstream of that the
the issue with next-gen sequencing is
that the the workflow is often kind of
complicated in the data analysis is also
complicated and it can tend to be kind
of expensive as well so again it depends
on the nature of your laboratory and
type the questions you want to ask
next-gen sequencing can be used to
quantify the types of edits that you
have made and and the types of sequences
that you have present but again you know
going through the the the workflow and
the expense sometimes is not the most
efficient way to go about it but
certainly next-generation sequencing is
a valuable tool that can be used for
genome editing workflows Thank You dr.
Jackson our next question what are my
options
if the genome editing efficiency is low
so probably the easiest thing to do
would be to just redesign your guide RNA
and start again we have tools that that
will allow you to come up with multiple
types of multiple sequences for your
guide RNAs that you have different
options that you can choose you can also
try changing your transfection reagents
in other words using like affection
instead of electroporation for example
or maybe one of our lentivirus vectors
you know successively designed for
genome editing experiments that might
also help change your introduction of
the guide RNA into cells probably the
best thing you know if you continually
have problems you would talk to our our
synthetic biology group and our experts
that are in genome editing for guidance
and helping you decide what the best way
is to approach your problem thank you
and I want
our live audience today we have some
great questions coming in our next
question what are some of the selection
criteria to choose appropriate
technology for primary and secondary
screening so I touched on some of that
during that the webinar I think some of
the things that that are useful would be
to choose the the method that is most
appropriate for the type of Edit you
want to detect in other words the way
that you detect a random sloppy deletion
would be different from detecting a snip
and and so the text technology is used
for detecting that the Stewart
discriminate between those types of
changes you know be useful for that but
the other important thing so you know
are more practical things like you know
you the workflow the amount of time it
takes to generate a result the cost of
the experiment you know you know how
much you have to spend to get your
answer both in tons in terms of labor
and in materials the amount of sequence
information one get out of it you know
some of the methods do not actually give
you the exact sequence whereas others
like like Sanger sequencing or nester
and sequencing do give you an indication
of the exact sequence as present
yourselves so really there there are
many different variables so taking
account for this and there isn't one
right answer for for what's best for
your laboratory and your experimental
system again if you would like
assistance you can contact our technical
support group for suggestions on the
best way to proceed with your
experimental paradigm
thank you only have time for a couple
more questions our next one considering
efficiency is important what are some of
the tools available to analyze
efficiency so again one of the things is
most amost important one of the biggest
things you want to determine your genome
editing experiment is how efficient was
the edits that you were wanted to
introduce in your cells made this this
talk you know went to a lot of different
types of methods that are used for that
there's the genomic cleavage detection
assay there is digital PCR there are
Sanger sequencing methods
there's next-generation sequencing
methods and in some cases TAC men might
be useful as well so again I won't
emphasize there isn't one right answer
there a lot of different ways you can
get at the efficiency calculations but
of course given to how important
efficiency calculations are in dictating
you know how you go about the next steps
of your experiment it really is
important to determine what your
efficiency is before proceeding
thank you dr. jackson and we have time
for one more question because I want to
also provide you an opportunity for
final comments today for our audience
the final question I have heard about
the seeks to do could you share some
details about this instrument and
applications you can run
the Sikh studio instrument was just
released this year it is our new
all-in-one easy-to-use capillary
electrophoresis instrument it is
designed to be much much easier to run
and maintain than our previous
instruments that we have and meant to be
sort of used at the bench top of
individual investigators some of the
some of the applications that can run it
besides this genome editing techniques
of Sanger sequencing and credit analysis
there's a cell line authentication that
can be used there's clone checking of
your plasmids you know just want to
sequence whether or not your your your
plasmid construction is correct there
are methods for looking at inherited
diseases by friend analysis so the whole
suite of things you can do on our legacy
instruments can also be done on seeks to
do with the advantage that it's easier
to use and in some cases faster so we're
really excited about seek studio because
we think that it provides a way to
democratize capillarity phoresis
applications to our users and we again
made it very easy to use and maintain
thank you dr. jackson and i want to
thank our audience today i want to
remind our audience members that if they
have any additional questions dr.
jackson will be happy to email you
responses dr. jackson would you like to
provide the audience with some closing
comments yeah again I thank you for for
your time and attending this and we look
forward to working with you and your in
your editing experiments with that
basically any kind of experience you're
doing
we believe that thermo Fisher has you
know the expertise necessary to help
investigators with basically any kind of
experiment they're doing and if you
would like help in your genome editing
workflows please contact us and we'll
provide whatever assistance that we can
for you so again thank you for your
interest in time and we look forward to
hearing from you
and thank you dr. Jackson and thank you
for your important research I'd also
like to thank lab roots and thermo
Fisher Scientific our sponsor for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May of
2018 you'll receive an email from
Labyrinth letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye